1 cette ville
mâcher
van petite fille
j'ai vécu la viola violences deux petits
garçons j'en ai parlé déjà plusieurs
fois mais j'ai subi voilà des violences
sexuelles perpétrées par un petit garçon
et ça a été extrêmement durs
le com comme les adultes s'aveuglent
[Musique]
ensemble
beaucoup de nouveau pris conscience
d'une d'une injustice d'une violence
d'un silence qu'on gardait alors on a
décidé de reprendre cette chanson c'est
un appel à la solidarité entre les
femmes la différence de traitement oui
moi je l' ai vécu du gt petites filles
en âge de comprendre en tout cas de me
demander de me poser la question savoir
pourquoi mes frères avaient le droit de
faire ces choses certaines choses et pas
moi et moi j'avais le devoir de faire
certaines choses et pas mes frères mes
frères pouvaient rester dehors
jouer avec leurs copains jusqu'à 23
heures et moi je devais rester chez moi
à partir de 20 heures
j'étais coincé à la maison
[Musique]
je me souviens la première fois qu'on a
ensemble avec sylvie composé une musique
pour un film
quelqu'un qui était là la projection et
mino voir et nous a dit alors les super
la musique des films alors mais qu'est
ce qu'il a fait on a dit pas assez c'est
nous oui mais la musique qui est ce
qu'il a fait
ben c'est nous oui mais enfin vous
chantez mais il n'a pas permis un
instrument les la musique
bah c'est nous alors qu'une femme crée
de la musique ça semblait incroyable
[Musique]
hamon
bon
je pense qu'on se regarde plus je pense
qu'on sait qu'on n'est plus seul et que
les voies peuvent être entendus qu'elles
soient écoutés et que ouais on n'est
plus dans la même solitude depuis mis
tout et même même avant sûrement mais je
pense que ça a renforcé les choses il ya
beaucoup de femmes qui font des choses
entre elles des deux clubs de fondations
et les quelque chose qui qui est en
train de naître je crois
debout deux bouts d'chou
[Musique]